[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN:
Welcome to release 7.8
of Google Play Services.
You are here because you
want to build better apps,
and that's exactly
what Google Play
Services is all about-- allowing
you to build better apps.
Let's get started with the
highlights in this release,
because we are excited
to present some really
new cool stuff.
Let's start it off with--
yeah, that's right.
We have a new API.
Let's welcome the Mobile Vision
API with a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
The new Vision API enables you
to build really amazing things.
One part of it is
the Faces API that
allows you to detect faces
and different characteristics
of faces in images or
even in real time video.
So here, for example, are
some of my friends working
at Google.
And as you can see, the
location of all of their faces
has been detected
by the Faces API.
And faces can be detected
in different angles too.
It doesn't have to be
oriented straight forward.
It can, for example,
be tilted and turned
and all the other
possible positions
that you can see here,
but that I don't have time
to perform with my own head.
And once a face
has been detected,
you retrieve the
different landmarks
in the face-- for
example, the location
of the eyes, the mouth,
the cheeks, the nose
space, and even the ear tips.
How cool is not that?
And believe it or not, you
get even more with this one
is my favorite.
You can detect whether
certain facial characteristics
is present using
classifications-- for example,
if an eye is closed
or open, or how
much smiley-ness the face has.
For example, this here
would be close to zero,
but this one would be a
smiley-ness close to one.
And remember,
since the Faces API
can detect these things
in real time video,
you can create really cool apps.
Let's look at one in real life.
So here I am,
sitting on the sofa,
trying out an app
that uses the Faces
API to detect if my eyes are
open and whether I'm smiling
or not.
Let's try it out, starting with
eyes closed and not smiling.
FACES API: I detect that
your eyes are closed.
Please open your eyes.
That's beautiful.
You should always
keep your eyes open.
Now wipe that grumpy grin off
your face and smile instead.
Lovely.
Smiling is good for you.
You should always smile.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Amazing.
As you may think now that that
was it for the Vision API,
but it's not.
You get even more, because
in addition to the Faces API,
the Vision API also
has a Barcode API.
So pretty much in the same
way that you can detect faces
in images or videos, you
can also detect barcodes.
So go out there and create some
great apps with the Vision API.
And remember, it has both a
Faces API, as well as a Barcode
API.
And it can detect things
in images as well as
in real time video.
In this release, we also have
announcements for Google Cloud
Messaging where we have
expanded notification
to support localization.
So you can now construct
notification messages
that will be displayed using
the locale of the device it
is sent to.
And to get ready for
the Android M release,
we've added high and normal
priority to GCM messaging.
This allows you to set messages
that need immediate attention
to high priority-- for
example, a chat message
alert or an incoming
voice call alert.
This brings us to--
yeah, that's right.
It's time to announce another
new API in this release.
Let's welcome the
Nearby Messages API
with a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
Nearby Message is a
cross-platform API
to find and communicate with
mobile devices and beacons
based on proximity.
You may recall that
in a previous version,
we introduced a
Nearby Connections
API that allows you to
discover other devices
and create connections,
allowing them
to communicate in real time.
Great for local
multi-player gaming
where players can
use their own device
as a remote control connecting
to a central game server.
And now we're extending
the Nearby API
with the introduction
of Nearby Messages.
Nearby Messages
allows your users
to find devices and
share messages with them
through a Publish
and Subscribe API.
This allows you to build apps
with rich local interactions
between devices.
For example, to collaborate
on content, forming a group,
vote on something, or
broadcasting a resource.
So how does Nearby Messages
send these messages?
Well, first of all, it can use
the Bluetooth or Wi-Fi signals
to connect and exchange data.
But it goes even beyond that.
Ultrasonic sounds can also
be used to transmit messages.
That's right.
Sounds that we humans cannot
hear and that contains
the information.
That's pretty,
pretty amazing stuff.
And there's even more.
This API is also used to pick
up information from beacons.
So beacons are these devices
you can put up that broadcast
information through the
Nearby Messages API.
And any device that is close by
can then pick this information
up and act on it.
And that's it for this release
of Google Play Services.
But be sure to check out
these resources as well.
Now you have some work to
do to use these fantastic
APIs to build better apps.
That's right.
Go out there and
create some great apps.
And don't forget to
tell us all about it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]